Alright everybody, welcome to another League of Legends entrepreneur ask me anything question
joined by our usual co-host, RishyCupTV.
Good morning everybody, thanks Evan.
We also have my cohort in crime here, Mr. J-Ryze Fonseca, who's in the room with me
here and is going to be dual queuing with me.
So what's in the cup today, Rishy?
Well I've got a cup of love for Believe Nation and I also have a cup of Hymer and Teemo.
Cup of Hymer and Teemo.
That's it, we're going to try to get it.
We're going to try to get Hymer and Teemo.
I'm on Teemo, J-Ryze is on Hymer.
We'll see.
We're experimenting some new strategies that seem to be going well.
We want to get the win streak back, although J-Ryze did point out to me today that the
loss that we had wasn't streamed on Twitch.
Ooh, that was the problem.
That might be what the problem is.
So we'll see.
It has nothing to do with me.
So I'm queuing up for Jungle and Mid and J's got our game going and we'll see when we get
some...
Oh, are we in?
Oh, now we're in.
Now we're in.
All right.
Well, as we wait for a game to start, why don't we dive into some entrepreneur questions.
Great.
First question is coming from Simeon.
Simeon is an aspiring entrepreneur.
He's young and he's currently studying computer science and he hasn't mentioned what he wants
to do, but he says, I want to create projects, do interesting stuff.
He's really excited to work really hard and basically he just wanted to know, as entrepreneurs,
you're constantly getting these ideas and he wants to know how can you distinguish a
good idea from a bad idea because he doesn't want to pursue something that isn't a good
idea.
So he kind of wants to know, how do you know if an idea is worth trying or not?
Great question.
My answer to this...
How about this?
While we're queuing up, why don't we give J, J-Ryze, come on in and give us an answer
because you're not going to be actually in the game.
Come on in.
Give an answer.
We may have to rush if we've got to queue up, but you got to get in.
There you go.
You got to be a little closer.
All right.
My rush answer for this one is if you can't figure out an idea is good or bad just by
analyzing it, experiment, practice, do a small test and see if it gets traction and momentum.
And if it does, do a bigger test and if it doesn't, probably not the idea for you.
I love it.
Short and sweet.
Love it.
Look at that.
Love the energy.
J, what's in your cup?
Oh, we got a game going on right now too.
That was timing.
All right.
Good.
Experiment.
Rishy, back to you.
What do you got?
For Simian.
Simian?
This is for Simian.
Yeah.
You want to take it?
No, no.
You go.
Go for it.
Cool.
So I absolutely agree.
Just test it out and see how it goes and I was thinking too about one of the ways that
you can tap into value is by scratching your own itch.
And so I love what Steve Wozniak said about he created things for himself, things that
were fun for him.
And so sometimes I think the best way to just find out if you have a good idea is say what
I want then and then create something out of that.
I like it.
I'll continue the theme that we got going on.
And by the way, J-Ryze is top.
I'm jungle, so not quite the positions that we wanted, but we're still getting the game
on.
Oh.
We still got our synergies that'll work.
The answer is you don't until you try.
You don't know what's going to be a great idea until you try.
And some things might be ... Oh, I got to ban the champion, do that properly here.
Some things will be, when you start them off, they'll be amazing and you'll love it
and you'll want to do more of it and you want to get lost in it and you want to continue
to experiment and keep doing other things.
And sometimes you'll get into it and it wasn't what you thought it was and you kind of, you
scratch that itch and it's not something that you want to build a business around.
And so to J-Ryze's point, you can only analyze for so long, right?
Like you can think about an idea and you can write down the pros and cons and you know,
you can do that for thousands of ideas, but you're not really going to know until you
actually go out and do something.
And so my advice to Simeon is when you get an idea, just start.
Like what's the smallest start that you can do to test it out?
Because a lot of entrepreneurs go with these big ideas, these huge ideas and you know,
as entrepreneurs we come up with lots of ideas and so you may have a hundred huge ideas,
but you're never going to get anywhere unless you actually start and you won't actually
know if you like it, if you'll be good at it, if you can provide value in it until you
actually go out and start it.
There's a lot of different ways to make money.
Like any of those ideas that you have probably could be successful.
You can find ways to add value in any industry, but the key is like what's the best thing
for you?
It's not necessarily the best idea because there's tons of great ideas.
What's the best idea for you, for your skill sets, for your passion, for what you want
to do, for what you want to inject into the world?
And so that's it when you get the smallest idea, like you get something like, hey, here's
something I'm curious about.
Just go out and try it.
And that's something I try to train myself to.
You know, the top 10 video series was just an experiment.
It was a small test.
It's like, ah, it'd be cool if I had these resources from famous entrepreneurs, their
best interviews all cut into one thing.
That'd be awesome.
Let's do one.
But let's plan out the perfect plan and take six months to build the team and, you know,
all of this stuff and make this huge project that then never gets done because you need
to have the perfect plan.
It's just let's do one and expect it to suck and then the next one will suck a little bit
less and see if I like it because there are some things that you can do that you will
do that once you get into it, you don't love.
And it sucks when you've invested tons of money but also your time, like if you spend
six months planning a business and then once you actually start it, you realize it's not
the business for you, that's a big waste of time where it's better to go out and try and
try and try.
These League of Legends things, this is another experiment.
I like to play League.
I like to answer questions.
Maybe we can combine them.
We did one together.
We liked it.
We're doing more.
We could have done one and done.
And so just start.
Whatever the idea is, break it down to the simplest, easiest, smallest way to get started
and go out and do and see what makes you come alive.
I have a really quick follow up to that, Evan.
Being that your top 10 has been I think your most successful series on your channel, did
you have anything intuitive in you that was like this idea is going to be over the top
or was it just like every other curiosity you had followed, you just didn't know and
you just experimented and then it just took off?
I'm excited by all my ideas.
You know, like a lot of the stuff that we've canned, I was excited by at the start, right?
Like the end series.
I don't know if you remember the end series.
I love the end series.
It was one not, so the end series was basically taking two entrepreneurs or two people who
were having success and it sounds like they're saying the opposite and the idea is like if
you can understand both points of view, that'll make you a more successful human being.
I like that idea.
I thought it would be something epic and it came from watching a Tupac Shakur video where
he was talking about being humble as sexy and I remembered another clip about Kanye
saying you know, don't be humble, be great and so okay, let's put these up against each
other and not to create controversy like who's right but more, they're both right and your
growth comes from understanding the other point of view.
I love that idea.
I thought it was a really cool idea.
The audience kind of liked it.
It was not our best performing series and we started having a hard time finding enough
clips of people who were recognizable people who were saying opposite things and so.
We killed the series.
There's been a lot of other series like has anybody written hey, where's that end series?
Nobody at least that I know of.
I wrote it in my head.
So it's fine and you'll have more losses than wins.
You'll have more L's than W's.
That's fine for every top 10 video.
I'm always trying to beat it.
We have our Saturday morning just an example.
The Saturday morning series is a rotation of different ideas.
We're doing morning people's morning routines.
We're doing some Steve Jobs videos.
We're doing some favorite books, videos of entrepreneurs and there's been other ones
that we've just cut and I'm trying to beat it.
I'm always trying to beat it to see can we get this into a regular schedule and it's
combination of do I love it, am I getting passion from it and is the audience reacting
to it?
Is it leading to subscribers and comments and engagement?
Is it having the impact because I want to have an impact.
So I'm excited by all the ideas and then I go and test it out and I think that may drive
my team a little bit nuts to be honest.
You know Ivan is my researcher and Christina leads my editing team and you know the number
of times they get an email from me at two in the morning that says idea!
Exclamation point!
Can we try this?
And thankfully I have a team that embraces that change and likes to do new things.
You know like my seven ways series is something that I started that was new where you know
my seven favorite movies are seven ways to whatever it's every Wednesday I think it comes
out at noon.
And that was something I was interested in sharing and we had no branding we had no icon
for we didn't have any intro for like all the stuff that usually you might say I can't
launch this video until I have this stuff right like at the bottom left there's always
the plain logo and the other logo and some of the series have intros on them and some
of them don't but like I would rather get it out there see how I feel about it did I
enjoy the process of creating it do I want to do more of them did the audience react
to them and so you can't tell like I love all my ideas and then I want to and then I
go and test them and then and then sometimes I fall out of love with the ideas and sometimes
the market punches me in the face and say we don't like your idea and then do I want
to do I want to tweak it and try to find more value my like if I really love the and series
so much so deeply I could have found a way to make it work I'm not as attached to it
as some of the other things I'm working on so I'm happy to let it go and do something
else we are in game and so I feel like too many people are trying to find the perfect
idea and and you won't it's like it's like trying to marry somebody just looking at their
eHarmony profile like you can't right like no matter how good a profile they have and
their pictures and videos are there videos in eHarmony I don't know I've been on eHarmony
you know whatever hey J-Raz you're top man J's going mid too used to the mid strat yeah
no matter what their bio says and you know their pictures and all that stuff you will
not marry somebody based off of an eHarmony profile and if you do then then you're probably
making a mistake like you have to meet them you have to go for a coffee right and so instead
of instead of just spending six months waiting for the perfect person to show up on eHarmony
you want to go out and meet some of the good ones some of the people who you see something
in and set up a coffee date and see how it goes I think too many eHarmoniers are so focused
on making a mistake and picking the wrong idea and they invest too much into making
that one thing work where they may not love it once they start so find the simplest way
to start and start yes awesome advice cool we got a game going let's go to the next question
the stream is working too I'm excited about it super cool all right next question comes
from Brian and Brian is probably a dumb question but he wants to know how do you record the
interviews that you conduct ie Stephen Kelly are using Google hangouts or another application
tool he wants to start incorporating interviews on his website but he's not sure where to
start and what tools to use a very good question and Evan it looks like it's kind of specific to
what you're doing I know for me personally I've been using when I was doing interviews that was
using blab and blab is now shut down so right now I don't I don't have a live platform until
I move over to YouTube live but what are you doing Evan yeah so I do everything through Google
hangouts at the moment and and I would like I would rather do stuff through YouTube hangouts
and it's a pretty simple technology right you just need a microphone and a webcam and you're
in business and you look at my channel you know at 400,000 subscribers I'm just sitting here with
a microphone and a Logitech webcam and that's what I'm using right now like you like the settings
that I've got on I have no lights I'm just facing a mirror it's pretty low-tech pretty simple pretty
easy like don't let the gear hold you up so for a channel even you know as big as mine I'm still
just using YouTube hangouts now there are some changes coming and in September Google hangouts
is no more and so YouTube live is the thing I don't know I don't know if you can bring other
people on YouTube live which which is gonna really suck if you can't so I have to figure that out
wait oh you think it would just be broadcasting yourself and you can't have guests well a lot of
the other live streaming platforms yeah Periscope and Facebook live and all that stuff you can't
bring people door right it's just you use it from your phone or tablet and so I'm I'm I'm hoping
that I can still bring people on through the YouTube channel so that it broadcasts live but
yeah we'll see we'll see what happens in September it's coming up soon yeah I'm not happy about this
I know I love blab to Tim Schmore introduced me to blab I've done a number of labs they had a
really cool technology and it's interesting that they're shutting down just before YouTube
switches over mm-hmm it was an awesome technology but just look up just look up YouTube hangouts or
YouTube live probably by the time you get this and get to digest at all and hopefully there's
something in there for you that's what I use pretty low-tech pretty simple pretty easy yeah
there's always great tutorials you can find on YouTube about how to use that technology and I
know right now I've done the search and right now there isn't anything up to date until September so
I would look out for videos that come out in September from you know how to channel so that
you can find out how to use the technology better yeah when it rolls out yeah you could follow if
you're a fan of the channel you can follow what I'm doing too I mean I'll need to figure out some
kind of solution yeah but yeah coming up I can imagine it's like next week I can't imagine they're
not gonna let you have someone else on with you too many people depend on like if if hangouts on
air is getting absorbed too many people have like whole businesses built on their interview abilities
so I I would be surprised if they don't keep that feature you know YouTube's a Google's a strange
bird like a lot of people build businesses on the backs of Google Plus and they're there like they
they you know a lot of people loved using their RSS reader I loved using Google RSS reader and
they still killed it like if they're not getting Google wants to make products that is are having
big impact have big usage and if it's not getting the impact that they're seeing they drop it you
know so if a thousand people need it for their business doesn't matter they'll kill it and do
something else but it does make sense to be able to have it and maybe I just haven't looked into
it enough you know I think I think and I might ask him too much more about it too I think he's
done live events without using the Google hangout tool think he uses another system so so I'll see
but yeah it's coming it's coming it's like next week it's coming up so I got an interview with
Tony Robbins coming up soon so I have to figure out how I'm gonna do it but that's the thing too
right like I'm gonna interview Tony Robbins for the channel and I'm gonna use Google Hangouts
right like don't get so caught up with the tech right the tech doesn't matter like yes it matters
a little bit and yes lighting helps and yes good you know audio helps and a good camera helps but
it's not the deciding factor like if people invested more time into making themselves
better the content better you have way better results than if you get the nicest camera in
the world but you still suck on camera and it's funny to the point of our last call the last
question that we had about good ideas and bad ideas it shows that you know even a business is
as big as Google we're saying they're constantly trying new ideas some of them work some of them
don't and when they don't they just drop it and try something new so everybody's always trying
new things and seeing what works and what doesn't and you got it you got to be flexible to keep
moving right I like it all right we're losing so far in this game who who's who died I haven't
watched okay mid died twice you didn't die did you die you're good your eyes is good okay all
right let's go all right next question comes from Jamil and Jamil asks oh this is exciting he feels
like he finally came up with his one word ah Jamil Jamil mm-hmm and yeah very cool and so he he
really thinks his word is dream dream okay but the only thing he's concerned about is that he
feels like it's just not as effective as say your word believes or something like wind they kind of
just wanted your feedback on that because it sounds like he wants to be he wants to use dreams
but he's hesitant it that it will be effective all right just so commercial interruption J-Ryze got
his first kill so shout out there good job today rise all right dream so you know I really think
if you're guys telling you believe I mean dream is your one word you have to believe in that one
word I mean you know I've seen all kinds of different one words and just to use myself as
an example my one word is cup and you know you look you look at that and you go well that's not
going to be effective it's not even a verb you know you're you're not even selling it's not a
command into action of any kind it's just cup but for me I found that cup was the symbol that
represented the most of my meaning and and values for my channel and so I am learning how to
incorporate it in a way that is effective and that I think will be useful and so I think the
main thing with one word is that you just got to really believe in it yourself and who you are and
the values that you're bringing with that word are going to come out in what you do with your business
so that's my two sons I like it J race got another kill yeah good well it's doing well don't mess with
the J rice timer so two things come to mind when I think about this question the first is the
effectiveness of your one word is really through the lens of does it help you make important
decisions because all of the important decision that you're gonna make in your life should be
through that lens so if you think about you know I don't know if he's an entrepreneur yet or what
he's doing but you think about like the business you're gonna start the core values that you're
gonna have the people that you want to bring on your team like do you want to hire people who are
dreamers in your business is that super important for you or does it not matter right do you want
to hire winners in your company or do you want to hire I forget what his other word whatever what
the other one that he thought would be more effective then Oh when believe in when is what
he was thinking so like yeah so believe right you know my video editor Christina you want the
tattoo believe on her arm seriously that's before I even met her like it's just Wow oh you mean not
because she did not because of me no it's not because I have a tattoo just like that's that's
who she is that's a reminder to herself and so like it's one of the reasons why we work really
well together right and she loves that we're all about and so think about the next tough decision
that you have to make and think about the guiding principles that you want to have for you for your
your life and your business when things are really tough the one word becomes the lens and the answer
so does dream solve that for you or not the second the second part of that and that's for
everybody right when you're trying to figure out when your one word is the second part of that is
don't don't look at my execution and feel like you can't live up in you in your word right like
you're comparing my middle to your beginning you can build something amazing off of dreams like
what did Walt Disney do how many quotes does he have around dreaming and so just because you see
me doing well with believe and putting in all my branding and you watch the videos and you know
whatever you're doing to follow me don't let that make you feel like you can't have similar success
like it's easy to Jerry's is on us killing storm here it's easy to look at somebody else and say
they're doing it way better than I am mm-hmm whoa you got a double kill I'm not doing anything this
game it's all it's all it's all Jason Fonseca here ladies and gentlemen they're seeing the
notifications come up the Heimer got another kill in tower nice did we get first tower we
did nice holy cow I don't really have to do anything I just have to be around Jason and win
let's see let's see if it pays off yeah it's easy it's easy to look at somebody else and see how
how well they're doing it and there's a temptation saying I want to do it exactly the same they're
better than I am where really your success will come in doing it your way like just because I've
had success with believe when I started believe nobody liked it like it wasn't this you know
people thought I was nuts you know I thought I was nuts really yeah I thought it was too big an
idea I thought it was too too crazy you know I thought I thought I need to be more specific I
thought I had to be more more details you know I had to be just for entrepreneurs or you know I
don't know it was a crazy thing like who builds their life and business around one word so you
know I didn't have all the answers going in at the start they got dragon that kind of bothers me
so don't pick believe because you see me having success with it pick the one that you think is
really true to you and that's with anything like don't pick a business because you see somebody
else having success with it you pick the business you pick the life that is gonna fit for you and a
lot of times you have to tweak and experiment and prod and figure things out because there is no
there's no defined path just for you you got to figure out your path and yes you can model success
and you can learn from others but if all you do is follow one blueprint you won't get to where
you need to go you have to figure out your own unique path that is special for you that's my
thought cool dream on dream on let's hear it Rishy go high go high I love it I know she can
sing I can't sing I know you can sing I mean I can sing I know you can rap to that I know
I was I was in it that was a good attempt I'm proud of that round okay let's move to
the next one let's do it next question comes from Harold Harold aka coach ballast in the
coach and he what are the best ways to monetize you dude hey wait is this is this from New York
this question yeah is Harold from New York I can check right now I feel like I met Harold in New
York oh maybe maybe you did I went to New York for a interview and I every time I travel I like
doing a meetup with with my oh cool I feel like yeah is he maybe not I'm looking now I'm just
searching for the email because this is I copied and pasted the question out of the email so I'm
going back to the original wall okay well okay whatever it is fine oh that's okay I'll I can
start answering the question and look for it at the same time so Harold best way to monetize I
have three things to say and the YouTube question and now Rishy loves her YouTube
questions what YouTube I love so number one obviously the biggest way that you can begin
monetizing although I would never expect to do this and make a lot of money and not until you're
a huge channel but monetizing your channel through ad revenue and so what you have to do is you have
to become a YouTube partner and it's super simple basically it's just a matter of you know signing
a contract with YouTube to share ad in ad revenue and you know that's a way that you can right away
begin start monetizing the second way that I've seen youtubers monetize is through sponsorship or
brand deals we've had a couple conversations already on previous episodes here about brand
deals and sponsorship maybe Evan can if if you want to go more into that because I know Evan
you've had you've made like $100,000 that you when you were a small channel with brand deals
and and then lastly is the affiliate link I know you can become an affiliate with places like
Amazon Target Walmart and you know it's like if you've seen those videos when someone gives you
their personal link to go buy a book on audible.com or on Amazon or whatever you know you get you get
a percentage of that money because someone purchased something through you but I do
believe that with the affiliate links you do have to have a website so I don't know if you have a
website that's another way that you can look into that. Jason is Jason is just a one-man army here
yeah he's a one-man army getting kills getting kills all over the map I think this is Harold
from New York City it is all right yeah I think so I love it okay so yeah I mean I echo a lot of
what Rishy already said here I would say I would say it depends on what your your goal is with it
I think a model that that I agree like advertising is a easy place to start it's all taken care of
for you so that's it's a pretty simple game to play you just need to be able to create content
that people love want to watch enjoy you have an opportunity to sell to your audience and this is
this is a model that that I'm not a huge user of where like if you're coaching people you could
create content around your coaching program right some value and people look at it and they love
what you're all about and say man I want to get I want to get Harold to come and coach me that man's
a genius and then you have your coaching program and you can make some videos talking about how
you have a coaching program and what you you know what it involves and how much it is and all that
stuff we're really the only thing that I'm like I'm not selling a coaching program I'm trying to
play a bigger game where I'm not trying to immediately monetize my audience like even
even looking at the book like now we're in kind of book promotion mode like I don't make anything
in the book in the short term I win like I place long-term bets that's what I'm doing oh can I go
help nice man I'm actually not doing great like in terms of helping my team out but but I'm in the
middle of a fight and I won huh I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I died I died sorry I'll be getting
distracted here by the game yeah so you know if you have if I was a coach I would be using YouTube
to then sell my coaching program and coaching package I'd be moving the free line I'd be putting
out a ton of great content about what it is that I'm coaching and then people would want to work
with you right like if people love the value some people will just consume it and most people never
pay you anything for it I mean that's how you do works most people spend zero dollars and don't
don't support the channels that they're they're watching but you know they're helping you with
maybe a little bit of advertising revenue but more importantly they're helping you build up
they killed my ZZ rap they're helping you build up the likes and the channel and the audience so
that when you have the 1% of people who do want to buy your video is showing up because you've
created amazing content so for me like I get brand deals like I don't do any direct sales it's all
from people coming to me all the people who are for the most part just freely consuming my content
they help give it the likes and the shares and a comment and the engagement so the video ranks
well and then that gives me more exposure and then that helps the brand find me or the book
publisher find me and so if I was a coach I'd be using that same wow these guys are going crazy
can I get a kill so close ha ha ha ha very exciting Teemo magic pushing some kills off the map yes
so if I if I was doing it I would create regular content that would make people not just not just
a sales pitch not just like here's why you need to buy my coaching program but regular content
that makes you seem like a great coach and that provides value even if they never contact you
just because the content is really good and some people will naturally just not want to do the work
like some people you could give it to them on a plate but some people want to get there faster
like they want they want it handed to them and they want to work with you directly like I get
asked all the time for people who want to do coaching do I have a coaching program can you
help me with my product my business whatever right this is like this is the extent of it
right I'll answer question on YouTube with Rishy but I could easily have a coaching practice if I
wanted to so yeah if I was selling that kind of that kind of business then I would I would use
YouTube to be more as a sales engine I do it for trying to dance also right like we're trying to
sell salsa classes and so we put up videos of our turn patterns from you know classes that we've
taught and also we've launched a new series where the the operator Alex is doing an ask Alex series
or he's answering questions and we want to add we want to give value but at the end of the day
what I'm trying to do is build up likeability and trust and authenticity and I want people to buy a
salsa class right it's a different strategy than what I'm doing on my youtube channel for myself
Jerry's getting the tower pretty good but if I was a business coach I would be I think that's the
most lucrative angle and then gives you a chance for a bigger play at a book at brand deals at
speaking engagements you know like I just got asked to join a board of a publicly traded company
here in Canada to help them with their business like stuff that I I would never have thought that
I would do that it wasn't on my wasn't on my my wish list right I never thought I would be advising
the CEO of a 15,000 employee company right I thought like why would why would a CEO of a huge
company want to talk to me like I'll tell his employees to go be entrepreneurs like I have no
corporate I didn't think I'd be a speaker because why would people want to hire me to come speak not
because I don't have a good message just usually the speaking gigs are for corporate audiences and
I'm gonna tell people to start their own business so why would they want me to come here and so I
think having a YouTube channel can one bring in some immediate sales for what you're doing but
then it could also if you build up a sizable audience lead to bigger opportunities and bigger
deals that maybe you haven't even thought of before so yeah if I was a coach that's what I
would do like I advertise would be there sponsorships maybe but I would try to sell my coaching services
through the channel yeah great and thanks for the question here old man I love it yeah from New York
Harold Harold hailed me a cab I couldn't get a cab I'm sitting there on the streets of New York
we left our Starbucks I have to get home to catch my flight and and yeah I'm like put my hand up and
he's like nah man you're doing it all wrong this is New York you're too nice don't be Canadian you
got to get that cab get to the airport like walked out on the street and got got me a cab
so that was very much appreciated so I'm glad we couldn't answer a question oh all right next
question comes from those be tra spectra all right and the spectra says how do I pick good
people how do I build a great team I've always dreamed of being a leader I love motivating people
in my class and by that I mean I think he's a teacher okay because he but he says that they
didn't like him and they were constantly making phone calls playing with Facebook making noise
and while he was talking so I don't know if he's the teacher if this is like he was that was his
classmates and peers but it sounds like he wants to be a leader and anyway it's kind of affected
him so much that he even stopped kind of pursuing friendships and different things because I guess
that experiencing was pretty discouraging so yeah and he just kind of wants to know how do I how do
I build a team when I haven't had success with just dealing with people so yeah I mean I've heard
a lot you know that like for example as an entrepreneur one of your greatest strategies
is to know your strengths and know your weaknesses and like focus on your strengths and so that would
then mean in this case like it might be the case that someone says well if you're not really a
people person you know find someone who is a people person to build your team or manage your
team or whatever but I do I do have to say that I think that with people who really have a hard
time socially even if it's not like you're ever going to be this super extroverted person like I
feel like it's super valuable for any person entrepreneur or or whatever especially if you
want to be a leader like to learn how to deal with people people skills social skills because
I just think it makes you a better human and so it might not be that you know you're gonna be the
best people person in the world but I do think there's something to be said about like intentionally
learning how can I improve my interpersonal skills like why do I feel people don't listen
when I talk like I think those are that's information that's important to get sometimes
I'll ask my friends like how are you experiencing me because I might be doing something that I'm
unaware of and I want their feedback so that I can change that behavior if it's affecting them
or myself negatively so I think a leader more than any person should really want to learn how
to grow in dealing with people and that's that's kind of my two cents I know I haven't you plenty
of great value as far as how to actually put a great team together but I don't know I really
ask people that I can trust like why am I maybe not so effective with people you know can you give
me some help so that I can improve you know all right um I was getting a different vibe from that
question so I'm my brain is turning a little bit kind of trying to you're gonna read it read it
again I was going in a different direction with it so I'm okay I'm gonna die I made it out all
right okay oh I died very sad okay here's what here's what I was like I was I was thinking along
the lines of of respect the people are not listening to you they're not respecting you
and that usually first comes from you respecting yourself and having standards and what you will
accept and what you won't accept and so that that is where I think the first healing has to come now
like now that I'm dead I can process it a little bit like instead of looking outward I would look
inward to start and and build up your own self-respect like build up your own self-love
first I think back to Nelson Mandela who was went to jail and had everybody all the prisoners in the
jail call him mr. Mandela which like doesn't happen right and imagine like your prisoner
and you're getting called mr. Mandela and sir that's not how jails work but because he demanded
it like he had so much respect for himself that he will not be treated in ways that are kind of
inferior to what he believes and so you know that's maybe an extreme case you're not going
to jail you don't have to deal with prison guards but before I got to the point about building the
team I would be looking at what can I do for myself to have more confidence in my message
set higher standards for myself have better definitions of what I will and won't accept
like if people are are are showing up late or are chewing gum or on their phones it's because
you let them do that right if it's a teacher in class you know there are some teachers that have
that that doesn't happen and so you need to stop letting people treat you in a negative way just
like people who you know are in a bad relationship like they allow themselves to be treated that way
and so that's why it's gonna keep happening where you need to stand up for yourself and set
boundaries as to this is like not acceptable and I'm a firm believer you teach people how to treat
you and so yes like team building is important and I hear that you you know badly want to be
a leader in and I love it you're gonna have the same issues with any team it's like it's like the
like why can I never find the right person why why does this always happen to me in relationships
well like what's the common denominator right it's you yeah it's not them it's you so fix you right
like that's really what needs to be that's what you need to work on then when you get into the
team you know you want people who are along with your mission you want people who who have the same
values as you you want people who you know we got to the one word discussion before like if it's
dream you want people who are dreamers there's a lot there's a lot that you can do around building
the team just I feel like you have to heal yourself first and you get that down then the team will not
not take care of itself but will be a lot easier because that's the real problem right and Evan
too like you know you were saying people at this point you know you people call you sir they you
don't have respect issues and I think there's something to be said too about like certain
things earning people's respect only comes over time like you can't you can't just demand respect
but not have a life that actually backs up why people respect you and he was saying like I love
motivating people in his class and sometimes I think people jump into one to help people or
motivate people but they haven't like earned the respect yet to do that so I think something you
really can't even get until you've kind of like I guess like what you said done the work in yourself
where you don't even really have to demand you your life coming your life commands the respect
because it's just like the proof is in the pudding if that makes sense so I don't know I think some
people jump into one to try to motivate or help people or do things but they haven't actually done
the first part which is like you know your life being something that people are going to really
respect I I'd make maybe just to add to that I think I think you can easily set a tone like I
don't know who you think is you know a great leader who would look up to you know if you
think about you know Abraham Lincoln or I don't know who like a good leader is like who first
comes to mind we think about leadership skills but like those people would walk into a room and you
would you would know like Abe Lincoln if I'd never heard of him like he goes to Mars and you know
there's humans on Mars we discover this human on Mars is a big deal you learned it first here on
this channel Abe Lincoln walks into a room he'll go and command respect like if people have no idea
who he is he'll command respect and I really believe that it's not about like I think what
you've done helps build up your own character helps give you the confidence but just like we
won ha we won the game the game yeah yeah we won Jerry carrying us hard I think just like you know
you look at a speaker a good speaker you know when they're doing a speech some people know who they
are and you know when they've showed up they already they're already sold and committed but
a lot of people have never heard of this person before but by the end of that speech they're a
fan and they're out buying their books and they want to learn more about their message and their
mission so I think there's a lot that just by when you walk into the room you know some people
have that presence and others don't and and a lot of it comes from that self-love and self-respect
and I think you like those people did the work yes like yes it's doing the work but it's not about
like the outward focus of all these people have seen what I've done it's more you have seen what
you've done and you believe you have value and you can have an impact and not settling for
somebody showing up later chewing gum or disrespecting you like if somebody calls you a
name and in your class what do you do like is that acceptable if you're in a relationship if
somebody hits you is that acceptable somebody trashes your idea is that acceptable and so
there's a lot of hard work that yes goes into building your character and building that self
confidence up but I think I think like you've all done it we've met people who have that presence
and so I think I agree in that there has to be a lot of work done but it's more you seeing the
value in yourself as opposed to other seeing the other people seeing the value if you see the value
they will see it we end on a deep note yeah believe believe that I see Zaino here in the in
the live stream Zaino welcome aboard I didn't we didn't give a shout out to Zaino during the
stream but just at the end there you go Zaino welcome aboard man appreciate it cool well the
victory streak is uh perhaps intact every public stream every twitch stream the twitch the twitch
streak is intact I guess so thank you guys we'll see you on Wednesday morning hopefully for the
next stream Rishy any final words cup of belief have a great weekend everybody I love it thanks
guys continue to believe and we'll see you soon